when he burst on the scene like
everybody was like Clive Owen oh I
didn't there he is that's his name he's
coming out Clive
[Applause]
Owen oh my God I love you so
much I'm so excited to talk
you um first of all Hi how are you it's
an honor to meet you lovely to see you
will you play behind the scenes with us
of course all right this is behind the
scenes with SL
Owens um okay let's start with Curb Your
Enthusiasm oh
my I highlight of my career it it was
why tell me everything what's it like
I'm the biggest fan of that show of all
the people in it and of him yeah what's
Larry David like he's kind of brilliant
he's kind of like the show yeah he's and
I also felt like I walked into a dinner
scene and there was you know the the
whole group of them and I felt so out of
my depth cuz they're so good and they're
so good at improvising I was going to
say I heard there's a lot of improv oh
you don't get a script you just get told
this is the shape of the scene and when
they get going you just have to sit I
thought the safest thing to do is just
be the straight guy do it as straight as
you can don't try to be funny against
these heavy weights okay
this is one of the best movies ever
Inside Man directed by Le starring
Jody Foster and Denzel washing there was
a funny story about how when when I
first got the script I didn't take the
mask off I go in the bank I put the mask
on and that was it for the rest of the
movie and he called me and I said why
would I want to do this so we met and he
took me to the basketball didn't mention
the film at all finish the game like I'm
I'm like this having the my oh like like
he was part of the game Talking yeah and
I was like I had the time of my life and
turned and said you doing it or
what I said after that night of course
I'm
doing oh that movie is so good and it's
so clever and I love it so much okay
your Academy Award nomination closer
Julia Roberts Jude
Law Natalie Portman and again directed
by Mike Nicholls the most the best the
best God you Mike Nichols what is the
first thought that comes to your mind so
I get a call from Mike Nichols did he
call you personally um no somebody
called and said you want to go and have
lunch with Mike Nichol I mean Mike
neckos and I had a lunch with him and he
said you want to play Larry I'm going to
do the movie of it and this is the cast
and I remember walking out in New York
into the I think we were in sort of of
like the West Village or somewhere where
we had lunch and I walked out and I was
it was like somebody give me a gift from
somewhere and it was an incredible
experience and he's a genius my Nichol
well you know Nicholls and may you know
was the first couple of comedy and then
he was married to Diane Sawyer who I
think is like the hottest woman on the
planet